وقعت قطر والمانيا اليوم مذكره تفاهم
لاطلاق الحوار الاستراتيجي بين البلدين
وفي مؤتمر صحفي مع وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه النيله انا لينا بيربوك اليوم
في الدوحه قال رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
الثاني ان الحوار الاستراتيجي مع المانيا
منصه مهمه لمناقشه ملفات الطاقه والتعاون
مشيرا الى انه بحث مع الوزيره الالمانيه
ملفات دوليه عده منها الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
تطرقنا في في لقائي مع معالي الوزيره الى
تعزيز جهود التعاون المشترك
ترسيخ مبدا الحوار في كافه الازمات
الدوليه وناقشنا اخر
تطورات الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
واكدنا على موقف دوله قطر الثابت من
التمسك في ميثاق الامم المتحده
واداره اعتداء على سياده
اي دوله واحترام وسياده واستقلال اوكرانيا
ووحده اراضيها في حدودها المعترف فيها
دوليا